by Anna Carlin on avoiding cascading
failures for time of use braces okay so
Oh cloud so this is joint work with
shuchi chala was right here and it
killed Devon or who I thought would show
up it didn't ah although he now has a
beard under Holroyd James Martin and
Baloo Siobhan ok so the motivation for
this work comes from commodities of a
temporal nature like cloud computing and
energy basically situations where supply
and demand fluctuate over time you might
have good stochastic models for what
that supply and demand is going to look
like over time and the arriving jobs are
basically interested in getting service
within a win a window of time and what
we're looking at is the idea of using
pricing on a per time unit basis in
order to bow it supply and demand an
expectation so this is what we're
calling time of use pricing and since
we're only balancing supply and demand
and expectation there's a question of
how well will such a system work under
the natural stochastic fluctuations that
happen so that's kind of the the goal of
the work to understand that so the work
is is within what my some of you are
familiar with as the prophet inequality
setting so we're looking at a situation
where resources are priced in advance
based on stochastic information about
job demand I'm assuming fixed supply in
this talk and only demand is stochastic
so jobs will then arrive in any order
and take their favorite resource given
the prices so a job will have a value
and it will be only interested in you
know it has a window of time of interest
it has it's only interested in resources
that are priced below its value it's
always going to want to take the
cheapest such resource that it can and
the goal is to price has to maximize the
value of allocation and the benchmark is
the expected value of the optimal
offline allocation so this is the
allocation you would get if you knew
exactly ahead of time which jobs would
arrive and you could assign them
optimally to maximize expected value so
let's just warm
with a very simple example that you vote
many of you have seen before suppose I
just have one resource and my stochastic
model is two possible jobs job one which
is certain to arrive and has value one
job to which has very high value 1 over
epsilon but is very unlikely to arrive
ok so the claim is that no matter how I
price in this setting my expected value
is going to be 1 whereas opt is going to
be 2 minus epsilon this is example Matt
gave so the problem is that you know if
I price below want above one and only
this job will be interested if I price
out or below one then this job will
arrive first we'll grab the resource and
so the online algorithm doesn't really
have a choice because they arrive in
this bad order low value to high value
whereas the offline can you know assign
to this one if it arrives and if it
doesn't arrive which has probability 1
minus epsilon then it gets this this one
and this kind of result has been X 0 so
that was a factor of 2 kind of
competitive ratio sort of situation and
this has been extended to much more
complex settings like for example the
work of felled in gravity and Lu chair
shows how to solve this kind of problem
when the buyers or if you have a set of
heterogeneous items the buyers are
interested in you know only one item
each buyer has a value for each item is
going to they're going to come in in
some adversarial order and based on the
prices each bar will choose their
favorite item given what's what's left
over and basically what they show is
given priors there's a way to set prices
so that the expected value of the
allocation is half of the expected value
of optimum but what we're interested in
this talk is approximations that get
expected value is you know very very
close to one okay so and that's that's
impossible even an example I gave on the
first slide you can't do better than
one-half a factor of two with an example
I gave before so a way to get around
that is to use extra capacity so let's
do another very simple example suppose
that I have be identical resources so
this is sort of imagine these
are the resources that are available at
time T only okay and have many jobs
demanding one unit of resource each with
a low probability of arrival so the
claim is that if B is large enough then
I can price so that I get you know
basically a lot of the very large
fraction of the social welfare so here's
kind of the picture and they'll be
useful for understanding later the the
model for the jobs is that each job has
a value I've sorted them from high to
low and each job has a certain
probability of arrival okay so these are
the key wise and so what I want to do is
set a price if I set a price at some
value okay then only jobs that show up
with value above that are going to try
to take the resource or one of the
resources that we have and the simple
observation is that if I basically take
the take sort of the high range of the
values such that the expected number of
arriving jobs is 1 minus epsilon times
the number of resources I have so if i
do that then that guarantees that the
expected value of those resources at
least 1 minus epsilon times the expected
value have offed okay then even if they
arrive in the order low-to-high each one
of them is very likely to be served
because you know we're very unlikely to
have more arrivals in the capacity under
this assumption that B is basically what
you need to get the tail to Chernoff
bound to work okay so epsilon to the
minus 2 times log 1 over Epsilon okay so
that's a very simple case where you you
know once we add some extra resources
then we can do very very well so here's
the problem we're going to discuss today
it's a generalization of that problem
now think of time was going left to
right here and I have a certain capacity
at every time slot so I have a certain
number of resources at each time okay
and here's the stochastic model of job
arrival it's similar to what we had
before so every potential job has a
value and a probability of arrival but
now the jobs also have a window of
I'm okay and what that means is that
they're happy to receive a resource at
any slot in this window okay so just to
observe now you know if every window was
of size 1 this would just be a bunch of
independent versions of the problem we
just talked about okay so the question
we're interested in is you know can we
set prices so that you know price the
the time units so that if jobs arrived
online in an adversarial order and upon
arrival each job grabs their favorite
available resource given the prices that
will still get this 1 minus epsilon
fraction of the expected value of opt ok
so the easy part of this problem is the
pricing just like what we did in that
simple example so what you can do is you
can formulate and solve a so-called
expected linear program that optimizes
for the value of the allocation that
gives it upper bound on the expected
value of the optimal offline solution
you can read the prices off of the dual
complementary slackness conditions will
guarantee that every job that would be
accepted by the lp optimum is assigned
to one of the lowest price slots in its
window which is happy for the jobs so
the hard part of this problem is so
basically you can this is a standard
approach that many people have used in
many settings and the what that
guarantees is that essentially the
expected arrival the expected number of
arrivals to any slot in their window
sort of which is the lowest price lot
for each job in its window is kind of
one minus epsilon times the capacity at
that point in time the problem with the
understanding to prove that this works
very well is understanding the
interaction between spots at different
times so if it joins us ever jobs you
know we will occasionally have overflow
just one second we will occasionally
have overflow and if a jobs assigned
time slot the cheapest price lot in its
window is not available an arriving job
then it may grab slots at other times
and we're worried about the potential
for cascading bad event
yeah I have all that stochastic
information at time zero so this is you
know this is obviously okay that's an
assumption here I oh sorry not this
basically i know this entire
distribution which is which is like a
list of jobs each with a value of
probability of arrival in a window yeah
so yeah yeah I don't know whether the
job is going to arrive at all and also I
just adjust to emphasize we want this to
work no matter what order they arrived
or no matter what order they grabbed
slots and stuff like that yeah very the
prices online that just drops it right
no I we're not going to well
theoretically you would be allowed to do
that but we're not going to be doing
that okay so okay so let me first make
sure you kind of understand what the
process will be once we've set the
prices one step we've set the prices
that the jaw each job will toss its coin
as to whether or not to show up with its
associated probability and it will start
you know exploring trying to get a
resource within its window so for
example this job here which has values
so I've already set some prices here
through the numbers inside let's say job
three here actually shows up so the
first its first going to try to grab a
resource of price one okay and then if
that resource is not available it'll try
the resource of price too and if that
resource is not available to try the
resource of price five and if all three
of those are not available then it's
going to give up because a is too
expensive for it okay its value is below
it yeah so but the jockey site you
thought the resources at a time that he
got right or so that you know any time
it wants any time it was so we are
assuming nothing about timing of
different events nothing okay it's just
so so that's the point you don't know
what will be taken at the time this job
could actually theoretically show up at
this
time and grab a slot then it could do
whatever it wants I can't think of it as
like intervals are adding to the future
one by one yeah yeah but we're not going
to make any assumptions about the order
okay the only assumption about this job
is that the only resource it's only
wants a resource in this integral that's
all ok so this so I described this sort
of hopping process of a job that you
know it tries to find a resource here
then it tries to find a resource here
then it tries to find a resource here so
that induces a directed graph ok on
these time slots ok so for example we
have an external arrival coming in here
and then you know the jobs would
potentially hop from here to here and
then from here to here ok if there was a
job with this window then there would be
an edge from one to eight if there was a
job with just this window there'd be
edge from one to five and so on if you
have jobs you know if you have slots
with the same value could potentially
have edges in both directions yeah I
missed what do you have information
about the lake distribution of the
demand at any time we have up front this
this entire everything that's that's
depicted here we have up front the value
the window and the probability of
arrival free stuff I have a list of all
that that for every single job or
distributed like this is the
distribution it either arrives or it
doesn't with this probability but the
the window is fixed the window is fixed
yes but then the window might be
nationally right that's what the window
might be inactive yes good okay all
right I think you understand the problem
okay so so we have an induced graph here
and the basically the main part we're
going to show that this pricing in this
way works very well and that we
basically need to show that cascading
bad events don't occur okay so let's
start with a very couple simple example
so a very easy example would be if
basically the hopping the directed graph
this
hopping process just looked like you
know you arrived at time T then you try
to plus 1 T plus 2 and so on okay in
that case I could just and we already
have the pricing that guarantees that
the expected number of external rivals
is it most 1 minus epsilon times the
capacity at time T with exponential
tails so basically we can just start at
the beginning and do a simple inductive
argument to show that the number of
forwards in it's very unlikely that
there are any forwards and then and if
you know but and then there's also an
exponential tail and so when you combine
that with the arrivals you you're very
unlikely to have more forwards and so on
okay this is the case it jobs are right
for risk right ah I don't even care when
they arrive it doesn't actually matter
when they arrive the point is that no
matter when they arrive okay the total
if I look at time one there no forwards
to time one right so I'm going to worry
about the possibilities their forwards
to time to the worst case for a job
arriving at time 2 is if it comes in
after those four words have occurred
right so yeah it is essentially left to
right that's kind of the worst case here
okay and yes I should have said that
right okay and similarly suppose that
the forward and graph looked like a
directed tree okay then again where the
indegree at every node was constant okay
then again a simple inductive argument
from the leaves up shows that every
arriving job has very high probability
of service okay so this is again so here
we're using the Independence of the four
words from the different sub trees and
yeah that's basically what we're using
and the fact that the worst case is if
they arrive in this order and then they
keep percolating up as long as they can
okay as long as they need to yeah yes
did you say yeah what happens if the
capacity is one yeah we said that you
can't do better than a factor of
one-half but you can't get to it what
happen this case you can in this case
that's actually was done essentially by
the Feldman it all work and other works
and so on yeah
so what I don't understand is if the the
sum of the number of jobs total was
larger than the sum of our capacities
then that clearly wouldn't hold true
right like that you wouldn't we've said
okay weep weep in advance we set prices
so that the expected number of external
arrivals at every node which a note here
course much a time slot is less than the
capacity of that note so the overall
expectation is below the expected demand
is below the supply at every single note
the arriving jobs you referring to the
arriving jobs that are willing to pay
yes well although other jobs have
already been like tossed out the window
okay yeah yes all the prices are set in
advance so the jobs so this is what one
of the nice things about that i'll just
mention right now is that from the
perspective of the jobs is completely
truthful you know we're not you know
everything is just great for them they
get to choose their favorite slot it's
all good from that perspective okay so
the problem though is when the graph has
cycles and multiple paths that meet at
the same note then the kind of simple
inductive arguments don't work okay
because the forwards to node3 depend on
what's happening at node to the forwards
to know to depend on what's happening at
node 3 even if there were no cycles the
fact that you know you have multiple
paths coming from the same node means
that the arrivals here are not
independent of each other okay so that's
kind of the issue we need to deal with
but we can't deal with that and so the
theorem basically says that you know as
long as we have basically the number of
slots at each node that corresponded to
the single slot case and a set of prices
that guaranteed I'm doing informal here
they set a prices that guarantee the
expected demand isn't too high and a
director forward and graph with constant
maximum in degree then even if the jobs
arrived online an adversarial an order
of four diverse area blah blah blah okay
so I just want to say that this
theorem doesn't have anything to do with
the prices anymore it's just the prices
were there to guarantee that the
expected external arrival rate was
correct but you know the serum applies
even in this even in kind of an abstract
setting like this okay so I'm going to
try to give you the idea of the proof so
the high level idea is to actually show
that the worst case load is when the
induced graph is kind of looks like a
tree and so let me try to give you the
idea here so for the rest of the
discussion let's fix a particular node
say time T and we want to bound the
probability of overloaded node T so the
probability that an external job just
one second arriving at that node doesn't
find a free resource at the very first
note it shows up at yeah Bobby when you
covered the tree case a couple slides
ago you said there was a restriction of
the tree has bounded degree um now that
you're pinning the entire proof on the
graph being a tree well my graph my
directed forward in graph has consum X
but has founded integrate great actually
you can add a log D here and handle
higher degree but anyway that's okay so
we want to we're going to argue that
with high probability of probability 1
minus epsilon every single job that
arrives is happily served at the very
first node it shows up at so the first
part is just to argue that for any fixed
set of arrival so for example here I
have three arrivals at this node and
three arrivals at this node 1 here and 0
here for any fixed set of arrivals if i
want to show i want to look at the load
at node 1 and what i call the load at
node node 1 is the number of forwards by
the way these arrows here represent a
job searching for a resource so this
blue job didn't find a resource here so
it tries here and then it tries here ok
that's kind of what this picture
represents so the first claim is that
for this fixed set of arrivals and my
goal is to bound the probability of a
problem occurring at this node I can
re-route these paths the jobs take
without that they
along a tree induced tree here without
reducing the load here so just as a
simple example you know if I just simply
rear out this blue path so that it goes
up here then when I ignore the parallel
lism here I have a tree ok so that's
something that you can do for any fixed
set of arrivals a fixed node we're
trying to bound and there's going to be
some tree you can rear out on that will
won't include that will maintain the
load at the node you're trying to bound
for that particular set of arrivals ok
so I mean I want to state this a little
bit formally but so here's the notation
I have the load the forwards and
arrivals on node1 given the arrivals and
so given a specific set of arrivals like
zero at node 1 1 at No 2 and so on and a
specific set of pads that the jobs take
and I said that we could rewrite along
some tree so there are many trees that
that you know in this graph rooted at
node 1 here are four of them ok I'm
going to call that set T of one and I'm
also going to call l1 soup tea the load
at node 1 if all the forwards were to
only go along this tree so suppose that
you know whatever jobs arrived if i'm
using this tree they always go like this
that's how the order that's how they try
to find a resource ok so the claim is
and this is this is not too hard i'm not
going to show any details other than
that example i just showed is that for a
fixed set of arrivals basically if the
load on the new if the load if node 1 in
my picture was overloaded then there's
some tree such that if I route on that
tree it's still overloaded ok yeah you
cannot figure out arbitrary right so you
have intervals so those are gone ok the
intervals are gone and what we have left
was that forwarding graph and I'm going
to allow the jobs to take any path they
want whatsoever that forward in graph
now the realities they would only take
paths that correspond to their interval
but I'm now this is what I was trying to
say that we've moved away from that
particular setting to a more abstract
setting where I'd simply have a grasp I
have a right number of external arrivals
divorce case is worse case so yeah yeah
exactly so the point is that it suffices
for us to bound the probability that
there's some tree at which node one is
overloaded now I have changed the little
a which is a fixed set of arrivals to a
big a which is a random variable number
of arrivals okay set of arrivals at
different nodes ok so we want to bound
this and basically what we want to say
is what's the probability that if all
the route though you know if I look at
the worst case over all my trees of the
load at node 1 for the arrivals that
it's overloaded the worst case over
these trees and so it's complicated to
think about multiple trees what I want
to do is combine these these trees into
a so-called Tree of trees and before I
do that let me just observe that I've
changed the names of the nodes to
reflect the path that the packet takes
in this tree so here then me the path
the packet would go from 42 to 21 so
I've named that node 4 to 1 and
similarly here it goes from 2 to 1 so
I've named that note 21 the reason that
we've done that is to make the following
picture clear I hope that you can see
almost told me last night to make this
bigger but I didn't so the point is that
what i can do is i can combine all these
trees into this so-called Tree of trees
what is this tree of trees it represents
directed paths simple paths towards the
towards node 1 all the notes at level
two correspond to one hot pads nodes of
level 3 correspond to two hot paths
where you have an edge from a node to
another node if you know after you take
the first edge in this path that's the
rest of the past okay so the point is
that that the color scheme is intended
to show that all of these trees
construction are embedded in the tree of
trees okay actually it could be
exponential sighs yeah could in fact
very much be exponential size but the
indegree at every node is constant if
the graph had constant in degree okay so
we're actually not going to care about
that okay so here's the thing the claim
now is that if I allow if I look I let
my arrival show up so here there are
rivals a 4 here they're our rivals a 40
a 4 a 2 a 3 and so on okay i have my
random arrivals and i want to argue the
claim is that if the maximum of one if
in one if the routing according to one
of these trees would result in overload
then routing on the tree of trees will
result in overload because in particular
it contains all of those trees happening
simultaneously I hope that pictorially
makes sense it's a little confusing so
basically what we claim is if I call t1
this tree of trees then the probability
that the node 1 is overloading the tree
of trees is greater than or equal to the
probability the maximum tree is
overloaded okay so the problem is I
can't use the you know the analysis for
trees that we had before because we no
longer have independent arrivals at the
different notes okay so so the beautiful
thing is that you're going to be a sip
I'm just going to do this fast you're
basically going to be able to replace
these random arrivals by independent
draws from the same distribution and the
claim is that that's only going to make
things worse that the probability that
the root is overloaded when I have an
independent arrival of the correct type
at each node is greater than or equal to
the probability in the original tree
okay and once we've proved this then we
can apply our analysis for trees to
upper bound thinks that it's good okay
so the key lemma I just want to show you
this because I think it's very cute i
had certainly had nothing to do with
coming up with it but it's like so cute
and so simple and so useful
I just have to show you so suppose you
have two functions that are non
decreasing and x and y are iid
real-valued random variables then the
claim is that the maximum of G of X and
H of Y where these are independent
instantiations of the same random
variable stochastically dominates the
maximum of G of X and H of X where we
have X that's the same random variable X
and this is actually two line proof you
know since let's fix some particular a
the probability is a maximum when I take
independent random variables is just the
product of the probabilities whereas the
probability that the maximum is less
than or equal to a when they're the same
random variable is in fact just the
minimum of the two probabilities
actually I drew a picture here that I
was too lazy to put in the slides so
here we have our function f of X we have
our function G of X and we have the the
values X might take so the so and I fix
a particular a so the probability that g
of x is less than or equal to a is just
the probability that capital X is below
x1 the probability f of X is less than
or equal to is just the probability that
capital X is below x2 but if I need the
max to be less than or equal to a then
basically I need just the minimum of the
the basically I need to look just at the
minimum of those I don't know if that
wasn't clear it's very simple you'll
look at this later you understand so so
the point is what this shows is here we
have the product of two numbers less
than or equal to one here we have the
minimum of two numbers less than or
equal to 1 obviously the product is less
than or equal to the minimum so that
gives us this that this holds for any a
which means the probability that the
independent version is above a is
greater than or equal to the probability
that the same with the same random
variable is above it so I just love that
okay so bottom line is we get that
theorem and we can use it to get the
cloud result and I just want to make a
note that there's more work and puff
than that because the forwarding grass
in the cloud setting does not have
bounded in degree and yet we're still
going to be able to get the same bound
we
had for a single slot but there's some
reduction you can do that involve
shortcutting forwarding paths that I
can't get into and we also have an
extension of the theorem to the case
where jobs want more than one slot like
a contiguous sequence but then the
number the capacity at every no needs to
be much bigger and so just a quick
comment on related work which I didn't
mention mostly yet so there's an
extensive literature on worst case type
results in this setting of this cloud
setting okay and this just so so I just
want to you know to compare of course
they're worse case so you know that's
that's a nice to have that very very
strong assumptions very strong guarantee
but they're generally not prompt in the
sense that you don't know your payments
right away even when you arrive right
away competitive ratios can be large and
they're generally not truthful with
respect to all parameters without some
additional assumptions and not as simple
so here this was just very simple we
price everything in advance and we let
the jobs do what they wanted to do okay
and then there's stochastic there's work
on online matching that's not truthful
there's some relationship to queuing
literature that is complicated that I
don't understand and ask Nikhil and okay
so that's it so the nice thing is we
have essentially no lost relative to the
single time unit setting in terms of the
capacity needed and that's it thank you
should be
yeah so I think that well the problem is
that this this graph the the resulting
graph would be would very high in degree
potentially and be very very complicated
so I mean you could use enough resources
to make it work but I think it would be
not interesting